let's go to focus go say what and for
that we're joined by jason kelly thank
you very much for Bloomberg and of
course we still have bill we have Bob
Greer and we've got from Nasdaq we've
got Brendan's we got a full team this is
a great segment about quotes that you
found yes so this is a really fun thing
we do we sort of span the world goes
throughout the Bloomberg Empire and we
look at what the most interesting things
people are saying that sort of gives us
some insights into what's happening so I
want to start in the world of private
equity and alternatives and Yale so this
is a quote as in University not long
yeah is it yes David Swensen one of the
best endowment managers on the planet
the most discriminating when you talk to
private equity manager is another
endowment they get this sort of wistful
look in their eye when they talked about
David Swensen and here's why what makes
Yale tick is their ability to get great
managers these are Swensons offspring
they have been inculcated nurtured by
the master they're really the next
generation and now that's all fine and
good but when you look at the chart of
how these guys have performed and you
look at what we're calling the Yale
premium these guys are killing it and
this was a Harvard this where they
traditionally get killed I mean ill is
the blue line there on top yellow the
blue line and then the protégées are the
yellow line there and this is all based
on looking at alternatives I mean that
was Swensons big deal was forget the the
public markets apologies and you know
and let's go to alternatives like
private equity hedge funds and venture
capital DC was the outperformer here
Matt seems to be moaning over there well
because I mean Harvard has a much bigger
endowment right right and if you graph
the two as I have on my Bloomberg
terminal here show off you up that
Harvard is doing seemingly just as well
in terms of asset gathering in terms of
how big their endowment is who's putting
money but as far as performing it's a
performant this is graphing the
performance from 2002 okay is it doing
poorly it was a pesky little day that's
no no no no we're we're what we're
talking about is doing the best with
what you got where Yale has performed
better here you go I see so you're
saying that this is because they're just
acting more money okay so let's go at
perform that's a cool let's go on that
the jennifer aniston five foot four
major perfect 10 okay Angelina Jolie
born no heart now it's time to look at
turn I call it a turn from the Ivy
League to commodities to commodities you
can afford a simple I wouldn't you um so
let's go to this one this quote it would
take a brave soul to wait in with both
feet into commodity now this is not a
huge surprising when she's looking at
this market but let me give you one
thing about the Bloomberg commodity
index this is the worst performance
since 08 and as bill Cohen and Bob
greifeld can admit or can can I can
arrest yeah anytime you say the worst
sins 08 that's bad another good really
really bad sign um so it's interesting
to see that what Goldman and others are
saying is this may actually get worse
this is to me a long all right give a 30
show for the last one all right third
quote a little more optimistic on a
valuation basis this is not once in a
decade this is a multi-decade
opportunity to be buying very cheap
assets so that's Michael Hudson saldana
so let's talk about this is Franklin
Templeton who's got outflows coming out
their ears they made massive investments
in the spring in in the energy space in
high oh bond buying things at a seventy
dollar price which then plummet it down
to a twenty dollar price and they are
losing investors in dro okay but I want
to be clear I think he's talking about
buying assets in emerging markets index
ago and Brazil and things like that it
specifically don't you can draw a line
between these two which is basically how
do you feel about China commodities
emerging markets ultimately both are
Abed on China if you think the landing
is going to be hard and prolong right
then obviously who would wait in with
one foot much less both right exactly